[Music]
al 5 al ser filings with me liu jing de
pictures memoria of the fire
[Music]
the fire that has devastated the largest
refugee camp on European soil is
the last chapter of Europe's shame as
far as some are
willing to go  turn the
mediterranean into a graveyard get
new anise spears with you flixster
sound a pain look for a product
for years the council has blocked a
common response that replaces
emergency solutions or exam pt
solidarity and love the fertile
güines trap evacuation en relocation en
our live union company meiners next
week turbine commission the present is my
gration agreement how to have we count on you
they shoot lippi at the moment of the ring the
main bar take care of the tour and
location he referred on that set no memories
or I don't think
efe can't do good  politician who does not
have a good heart and refuses to
rescue people and refuses to recover their
dignity shows that they are not qualified  or
to carry out this great
responsibility that we have as
Europeans